hey my guy you're a girl you're a girl
it's gonna be I thought it's gonna be a
sexy threesome wait look at me Jack Jack
look at me I want to look at your face
wait I want to look at your face give me
your face why your beautiful pixelated
face well look at me towards me I am oh
okay
let's go winnie is a scare obviously
scary Phil's here this is awesome this
is question of the animatronics no no
they are scary if you make fun of them
they will kill you the office I'm gonna
see 50 minutes what's he did you get
second to do it
turn off your lights turn off your
lights say this off but hey don't touch
my ass yes now sometimes at night these
animatronics get little hungry for the
booty so to protect your booty we've
installed these doors on each side now
you have to close when they come for the
booty shaggy catch our bad oh oh what
happened what happened whatever Wedeman
whatever that's moving I didn't see
anyone moving what the [ __ ] now moving
yet I'm moving yet look at the camera
look at the camera I'm not ready the
camera how do they know how do they know
her buddies are yeah Ken just can't down
I haven't come look oh it's moving Oh
what what's going on if you hear the
song we runs around you come to booty
space in the door you knew
okay I'll be the office guy and I'll
direct you guys to the line bear yeah
you did open the door open the door
you're wasting power what do you think
this is IKEA now we're fine we're fine
don't worry about it guys I won't let
anyone else have the booty look at this
door I've got my own [ __ ] section
pretty much your home yeah is he
stealing my buddy
oh Jesus Christ Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ Jesus that was the worst thing
I've seen in my life
Jason Jack what the [ __ ] are you doing
here every way every man for himself
he's running on the [ __ ] tables
hey my favorite I love you
foxy you're my favorite I'm like foxy
what ya said it what did you say
sad only like foxy you call me [ __ ] the
[ __ ] did you say bye foxy huh Wow no
I'll wash your doors and coordinate you
guys because you okay what we're all
dead
we're doomed it worked fine last time if
Jack did his job
it's my cupcake all right don't touch my
cupcake now they're not moving trust me
guys I am dead look just keep staring at
the button and trust me let's go to my
door ha Oh Bonnie yeah you closed it
you didn't even tell me yeah I told you
now
Rizzy you still out there still out
Jesus screams leave it don't way he's
going away he's cool okay you left your
post that's I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I back - cupcakes
no you're fine you know you guys are
green okay yeah cuz buzz cab down
you can yeah Vince is punishing kings
and bad man having this job
hey still there to do it what happened
what was that was that what happened
what happened I don't is then what
happened open the door you're wasting my
power beating power is free yeah it's
fine you're fine
what are you doing you idiot
oh no close me out don't close me out
don't cuz ya know we will protect this
cupcake no one gets their hand on our
cooking good job jack no no doors closed
okay dad he's like looking at me dude no
ass yeah I'm looking at you through the
Greg well I got his walking hat
I hear it's coming who's Jack Jack Jack
let's kid ken Ken Ken and what is it
it's fine you can open Oh as open let me
share there you're fine hey wait what
happened I don't understand exactly this
guy what what the [ __ ] happened gee who
let him out let him out
alright follow me follow me follow me
[ __ ] good
who are you come here Jesus alright we
need to get back in the office it's our
only chance
what are coming this way I think I see
one
this one okay ah buddy's coming babies
babies Kimmy we gotta go back to the
office back to the office don't run into
chica each person at a door I believe in
you guys
good job jack
oh god you're [ __ ] I let you in when
I can trust you oh god you're United you
gotta make it cuz foxy still gonna come
get you now foxy loving you it's only
one hour left got this what are you
doing or you just like sit in the office
with the door closed uh I am doing
important stuff
I am standing in my dead friend's
[ __ ] faeces yes it looks like it and
I'm trying to make a survive so my
friend's death wasn't in vain but I
guess that's not honorable for Americans
we don't understand Swedish there's
blood even on the projector English
[ __ ] do you speak it
oh you only got 10 minutes yeah I'm just
gonna keep the doors closed [ __ ] it I
don't want to risk anything
yeah what's always God talk she's out
Bogey's out that's why he's running you
like [ __ ] crazy
she say him hey keep running
why is [ __ ] yeah thank you guys saygus
19 night to do it all again he
practicing that time yeah who wants to
supervise no I'm still supervisor I
gotta do your [ __ ] job
one more like daddy you're out beer
Hansel
you're an [ __ ] Bonnie really he
showed me his eyes on how can i he's
looking in the window yeah hey guys hey
guys hey kids wanna play king can i play
with you guys
hey well you guys never you made me
nervous
guys careful okay Oh check it out open
open Jeff yeah it wouldn't wave a bunny
still here
nobody left bunny left you ready guys
we're not [ __ ] up now
you